a lot of Americans put kale in
everything I am Jonathan Grahm and I am
the chocolatier of comparte chocolates
here in Los Angeles being from LA I came
up with the kale chocolate bar because
every single menu in every single
restaurant was full of kale and I was
like you know what how do we get people
in LA to eat more chocolate this is the
answer ladle it into the mall just like
that and we're literally going to
sprinkle and blanket each bar with some
kale I'm going to add some pumpkin seeds
and then my last final bit I'm going to
take some of these beautiful sesame
seeds and just sprinkle them on like
that there we are vegan chocolate is
that even a thing there's obviously some
milk and chocolate right that's how I
like to eat my chocolate I'm vegan so I
haven't had chocolate in like over a
year Oh kale and seeds
all right kale hate kale a forest grew
on top of my chocolate get your salad
out of my chocolate bar
I don't know this doesn't look very good
gosh I forgot this flavor it's been so
long I wasn't so sure about the kale
because it just ruins everything
but in this chocolate it I do taste
pretty good the states kind of come
through it's quite nice actually not a
fan of it if I'm gonna get chocolate I
want it to be sweet I'm not mad I like
kale my chocolate maybe that's just me
no animals were harmed in the making of
this which is a plus so immediately I
see like this huge chunk of kale on this
chocolate I'm like what is this about
but then again I see this pumpkin seeds
I'm like mmm I love myself some pumpkin